all right welcome everybody it's great
to be back a lot of
uh good things to talk about some not so
good we're going to be going over
so much took place indictments rallies
so many different things during our
vacation but where i want to start is
with the latest on
coveted cases and deaths we're going to
do a deeper dive tomorrow
about what's going on on a
state-by-state basis but what is
increasingly happening
is that this pandemic is becoming
essentially
a red state blue state pandemic we now
have
different enough vaccination rates in
states like
hawaii vermont massachusetts and others
compared to places like mississippi in
particular
alabama arkansas that this
delta variant is wreaking uh drastically
different
levels of havoc in the more vaccinated
states
versus in the less vaccinated states and
the difference is only
going to grow due to the level of
contagion of this delta variant
believed to be reproducing and
are not somewhere between five and eight
the delta variant which is significantly
more contagious than the sort of
original strain of the coronavirus
believed to be somewhere in the
you know two to four two and a half to
three and a half range
and this is not merely a curiosity it's
actually having a real impact
and there's a new associated press
report that
nearly all coveted deaths are now among
the unvaccinated the the numbers are
just incredible
um the associated press writing nearly
all
coveted deaths in the u.s are now in
people who aren't vaccinated
a staggering demonstration of how
effective the shots have been
and an indication that deaths per day
now under 300
could be practically zero if everyone
eligible
got the vaccine an associated press
analysis
of available government data from may
shows that breakthrough
infections and fully vaccinated people
accounted for fewer than twelve hundred
of more than one hundred and seven 000
hospitalizations so that means
of those hospitalized
1.1 percent were vaccinated
compared to 98.9 percent of
hospitalizations being in those who were
not vaccinated and then
further only about 150
of the more than 18 000 coveted deaths
in may
were in fully vaccinated people that
translates to about
0.8 percent or five
deaths per day on average
only about 45 states report breakthrough
infections
some are more aggressive than others in
looking for such cases
so the data probably understates such
infection so there's a few
important details here to consider
one is at this point there's just no
question whatsoever about the level of
protection
that the vaccines provide including
against
the delta variant um some might say well
you could get sick anyway and you could
end up in the hospital and you
could die and of course that's true but
often the people saying that are those
who don't want to get vaccinated
seemingly failing to understand that by
they themselves getting vaccinated
they become less likely to pass on
any of these variants to someone who has
been vaccinated but might be in the
eight or so percent that has not
developed antibodies now one other thing
and we're going to look into this in
more detail tomorrow
there's a i don't even know about a
report that there's there's
we'll call it a report it's not it's not
a study but there is a news report out
of israel
a highly vaccinated country that they
believe
there may only be 64 protection against
the delta variant for the pfizer vaccine
remember that israel
started vaccinating very early
exclusively with the pfizer vaccine or
at least initially exclusively with the
pfizer vaccine and of course when you
see that and you say oh it was 92
percent
only 64 effective against the delta
variant some good epidemiologists
including dr ashish jah who we had on
the show a couple of weeks ago and
others have said
they as of now are unsure about that 64
number and sort of a two two uh pronged
response one we don't really know that
that's the number and it sounds
suspiciously low it's probably higher
than that but lower than 92 percent but
more importantly
um even though cases have started to
tick back up in israel
as the delta variant spreads
hospitalizations for now
are at least not up and that would be
the vaccine doing its job which is
preventing serious illness
preventing hospitalization and
ultimately preventing death so
regardless of your view as to the
seriousness of that variant
it still makes sense to just go and get
vaccinated because not only do you
protect yourself you also protect people
that may be vaccinated but either
immunocompromised or just in that
that you know it's on a bell curve
antibody development is on a bell curve
and not everybody develops those
antibodies
um the uh oh one other thing
there are immediately there are always
conspiracy theorists and i've seen
floating around
oh the people who were vaccinated and
died
died from the vaccine and of course
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
uh the vast majority of those folks were
vaccinated
you know months months before in many
cases
there's no evidence of that but remember
that that's how conspiracism works
and it should be no surprise that that's
the the way that some people are going
to react
i got an email from an er doctor um who
works in a less vaccinated
red state and he said they are
regularly seeing at their hospital that
just like the national data almost
everybody who's being hospitalized
and even more so almost everybody who's
dying of the virus
was not vaccinated and he said you know
i i understand that it's easy
not to feel sympathy for some of these
folks in some sense i mean listen
they didn't get vaccinated they could
have they got sick
then they died but he had a different
take which i think is
is reasonably empathetic which is they
fell for disinformation and in a sense
we
we should we should sympathize with that
uh they didn't get vaccinated because
they became convinced of things that
weren't true they were
victimized by purveyors of of
disinformation
and societally there is some
responsibility to that i i
i get that on the bonus show today i'm
going to tell the story
um from last week from my trip of a lyft
driver
who told me he wasn't getting vaccinated
because his mom
became magnetic after getting the second
dose so that'll be on today's bonus show
but um stunning stunning stuff
we had the fourth of july weekend in the
united states
a big holiday weekend lots of
fireworks which i can really do without
and um
cookouts and all sorts of different
things but we also had
an unconscionable number of shootings
and very often this doesn't get news i
will sometimes come to you and say hey
you know we had
15 shootings over the weekend and 70
people died and individually none of
these made
any headlines and part of that fact that
that is both
evidence that um we are
incredibly increasingly desensitized to
the fact that
this is just a regular part of living in
the united states and also because
increasingly shootings don't make
headlines it's less present in terms of
advocating for gun safety regulation and
laws etc
look at these numbers there's a cnn
report from last night
which says at least 150 people fatally
shot
in more than 400 shootings over the 4th
of july
weekend these numbers are now out of
date
and i actually went to the gun violence
archive which you can find at
gunviolencearchive.org
and i just started counting and as you
can see pages and pages
of july 5th shootings and with any
single one of these you can click on it
and get more information i mean just
randomly you know look at this shooting
in south carolina
denmark south carolina where one person
was killed
multiple shootings in greensboro north
carolina with people injured and you
just scroll
by in the second page it's all july 5th
shootings
the third page is all july 5th shootings
the fourth page is all july 5th
shootings and you just keep going
eventually
you get to shootings on july 4th but
it's just pages and pages and every
single one of these
could be a news story we're still on
july 5th
uh 192 people
killed in 562
shootings over the weekend now i'm just
talking about
saturday july 3rd sunday july 4th
and monday july 5th there's already been
shootings this morning there's
there was one in atlanta and a couple of
others um
if you go back further into friday there
were shootings on that day
think about these numbers 562
shootings on just july 3 4 and 5
and 192 people killed
um cnn reporting some of the details
from from some of these
um at least and again remember this this
was from last night so this these
numbers have been updated
at least 150 people were killed by gun
violence
in more than 400 shootings across the
country during the 4th of july weekend
as cities nationwide confront a surge in
violent crime
the data which includes the number of
shooting incidents and gun violence
victims nationally over a 72-hour period
from friday to sunday is still evolving
and will be updated
in new york where gun violence has been
rising to levels not seen in years there
were 26 victims from 21 shootings
and you can just go and look at whatever
city is interesting to you in chicago
83 people shot including 14 killed now
the article accurately points out that
gun violence and violence in general has
been up over the last year
this is something we've talked about
before and it's really important
not to get sucked into the
disinformation about this
republicans who were silent about mass
shootings during the trump
administration
except in very narrow cases where the
identity of either the shooter
or the victim was advantageous to them
politically those people
are now saying uh it's violence
everywhere under joe biden that's that's
really all they care about making a
political point
my suggestion is to number one zoom out
a little bit
and understand that over a 20-year
period over a 30-year period
violent crime in the u.s generally
speaking is down
we have a very specific problem in the
united states it's a unique problem
globally
when it comes to gun violence there's a
preponderance
of both firearm ownership as well as
availability of firearms in the united
states
that is not the case in just about any
other developed country and in addition
to that there's a cultural problem that
we've talked about i don't want to
rehash that right now because
what is missing from i hesitate to even
call it an analysis but what's missing
from the talking points from the right
about
violent crime is up in trump in biden's
america a few things are missing
from that number one violent crime was
up during 2020 uh during the pandemic
and donald trump was president at the
time and then
instead of blaming the president they
were blaming so-called so-called
democrat mayors in blue cities
so number one it's very transparent that
no matter who's in power
they will find democrats to blame and
then the truth is that this is a
far more complicated thing than there is
a democrat in the white house or a
republican in the white house
it's far more complicated than the mayor
or the governor
is a republican or a democrat this
relates to
economic issues this relates to
uh instability uh more broadly of our
economic system
exacerbated by the pandemic and what is
definitely a k-shaped recovery where
those that have done well have done
really well as we have
started to recover from the pandemic and
others have been completely left behind
so the the point here is not to
relitigate
every aspect of uh so-called violent
democrat cities which we've debunked
or of the fact that the crime increases
actually started
in 2020 when it wasn't joe biden that
was president it was donald trump it's
that you
as hopefully a savvy new consumer a news
consumer
when you hear these talking points
my hope is your reaction would not only
be is the talking point
accurate or not but a slight zoom out
where you say
is this even the right conversation to
be having about this issue because often
it's not
they want us to be having the
conversations that are advantageous to
them
and they leave out completely in this
case for example the economic
conversation
the violence started going up under
trump in 2020
it's continued going up under joe biden
in some cities in 2021
one was a republican one's a democrat
let's argue about that
is what they want when in reality the
conversation we should be having is a
different one
we'll continue tracking these numbers
and they're very ugly but i would love
to hear
from you about what else you believe is
causing this uptick
you can find me on twitter at dpakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount joinpakman.com
remember that we do depend on your
support to fund our
program you can sign up for a membership
today
at joinpakman.com i have
a i had a two actually pretty big
vaccine anti-vaxx run-ins
during my vacation i'm going to talk
about them on today's bonus show pat
will tell us what he was up to
sign up right now at joinpakman.com and
you can use the coupon code
indictment 21 if you would like
as we i guess we're sort of celebrating
the indictment on 15 felony counts of
donald trump's cfo it's starting to all
come off the walls and
we'll get to that later joinpakman.com
is the place where you can sign up
okay so donald trump had another one of
these rallies that he has restarted
over the fourth of july weekend i
covered it live and
tomorrow actually hopefully later today
i'm going to lay out
what i think uh will happen
if donald trump does indeed run in 2024.
i happen to think that joe and kamala
are in real trouble if trump runs in 24.
i i
know that there are some in the audience
who disagree with me and some that
vehemently vehemently do agree we'll get
to that later but in terms of the
rallies themselves
they're truly horrifying i mean every
time i cover one of these rallies i get
dozens of emails especially from foreign
viewers saying
david what is happening in the united
states uh these rallies
are dangerous this one was in florida
trump admitting to crimes during them by
the way we'll get to that
uh of course telling completely
corrosive easily debunkable lies about
american democracy and the crowd it it's
it's not even notable to say the crowd
believes it
there's not even the possibility that
the crowd might question
anything they're told at these rallies
and that's very scary
does the crowd have what we would call
an illness
i'm increasingly unsure what we even
call
what these folks are suffering from so
let's just start with trump confessing
to crimes during the speech
trump's business his organization and
trump cfo alan weiss
weisselberg have been indicted part of
these charges
uh relate to allegedly avoiding taxes by
having donald trump
directly pay for stuff for his cfo
over a 15-year period tons of stuff tons
of money
and trump admits even if only to part of
the stuff
saying not paying taxes on your company
car
or your grandkids education the
allegation is trump would directly pay
for weisselberg's
grandkids educations which really should
be income weisselberg pays tax on and
he's accused of not paying tax on that
that's what they're accused of and
trump's admitting it here take a look at
this
and yet they go after good hard-working
people
for not paying taxes on a company car
company car you didn't pay tax on the
car
or a company apartment you used an
apartment because
you need an apartment because you have
to travel too far where your house says
you didn't pay tax or education for your
grandchildren
i don't even know do you have to but
does anybody know the answer to that
stuff
okay so trump admitting to it and the
crowd
barely has any idea what trump is even
talking about but
trump is confessing to the crimes that
they have been charged with
in this case this actually helps him
and his followers if he just admits to
it in public this
has been a strategy for a long time you
admit to it in public
trump says it definitely shouldn't be
illegal the fact that there's a law
against this is me being a victim
of something and his followers just get
on his side
110 even though he's admitting to crimes
when others say listen okay
drugs fine but that really shouldn't be
a crime these law and order right winger
say
but it is and law and order means if
something's a crime you have to be
punished for it
when trump says is this stuff even a
crime
it shouldn't be a crime then they're
with him a hundred percent
and trump even pointing out during this
speech the strategy that he uses
if you keep repeating lies to your
followers your followers will start to
believe them
trump talks about it as if it's uh
applicable to democrats
but it's actually exactly what he does
take a look at this all of a sudden they
said today i heard and
there's a word disinformation is called
this if you say it
enough and keep saying it just keep
saying
they'll start to believe you we can't
let that happen because now they're
saying
the republicans wanted to to fund the
police i said
you know this is why half or more of
trump's followers
still to this day believe that he won
the 2020 election because trump and
others keep repeating it
trump then paints himself as a victim if
you can believe it
and he brings up hillary clinton yeah
it's 2021 we're halfway through 2021.
he's bringing up hillary clinton stuff
from 2015 and earlier look at this
from ukraine from china
they didn't go after hillary clinton and
her foundation
they didn't touch her they leave
democrats alone
no matter how bad they are but they've
mobilized
every power of government to come after
me
my family my wonderful employees and my
company solely because of politics
so trump as usual the biggest victim of
anybody
you'll see later in the show his
children also painting themselves
as just the perpetual endless victims
now then it goes totally off the rails
trump gets back on the statues stuff and
he claims without any evidence
that democrats want to replace the
jefferson memorial
with a statue of al sharpton which is
baseless first of all
it strikes me as probably racist in some
way
although i'm i'm trying to figure out
exactly all of the ways in which it is
take a look at this clip they want to
take the statue
of thomas jefferson out and replace it
with somebody
by the way let me tell you you're not
going to be happy with the person they
want to replace him with
ladies and gentlemen thomas jefferson is
being removed from the jefferson
memorial
and being replaced with the reverend al
sharpton
i don't think so so it's also really
stupid i mean i
i wouldn't want an al sharpton statue
replacing the jefferson memorial and i'm
on the left so it's just like layers
upon layers
of dumb gas lighting and then of course
no trump rally is complete without the
slurring part of the evening i won't
spend a lot of time on this
the speech went nearly two hours clearly
way too long
for trump and as the sweat poured the
slurring ramped up here's
trump saying that our ancestors crust
they crust fascism take a look
our ancestors christ just
absolutely crushed fascism beneath the
weight
so an absolutely absurd event
these apparently are going to continue i
think that this
is part of trump's plan to build himself
up and build up his influence going into
2022
and because you know normally i won't
talk about an election that's not the
next one
but i'm actually going to break my own
rule later on in today's show
because what trump is doing now is as
much about 2024 as it is about 2022 and
you really can't talk about one without
talking about the other so i'm going to
talk about that a little bit later
but next what i want to go to is to show
you
some interviews with trump supporters
that went to this rally in sarasota
florida
which is arguably even scarier than than
the things trump said himself so let's
get to that next
so okay trump does his rally in florida
it's riddled with lies
it's pathetic it's authoritarian it's
hypocritical
fine in the sense that it's what we've
come to expect and what we've come to
know
but understand that without trump
supporters
who are willing to stand around for 12
hours waiting for the rally
uh and are willing to it's not even take
in and accept it's
there's not even the possibility that
they would question any of the things
that donald trump says during these
rallies without those people there
really
is no rally it's just trump speaking to
an empty room
so let's look at some trump supporter
interviews
from the rally in sarasota florida and
this is going to set us up for our
conversation that i'll be having after
the break
about why i believe that if donald trump
does run in 2024
um it's not good at all for the biden
harris ticket i think biden harris are
in real trouble if trump runs
we're gonna get to that okay but first
trump supporters
here's one being interviewed by real
america's voice
and check out it's we've talked about
delusional before
this is not just delusional this is a
sort of
defiant and proud delusion
that is different than a lot of what
we've seen
prior to the trumpian era take a look at
this supporter a trump supporter
why are you continuing to support the
president so aggressively and
passionately
still right now in 2021 and this is a
key why is this a key question
you know real america's voice these
people are this is all terrible but why
is this a key question
because if we want to figure out what 22
and 24 will likely look like
this is the perfect question why are you
still supporting this guy so
aggressively he lost everything for you
he lost 18 in 18 he lost the house for
you in 20 he lost the white house and
the senate well but they don't even
believe that
that's the key because he really won the
election he loves our country
he loves our veterans um he wants there
it is
there it is uncritically accepting
there's not even a chance she wouldn't
accept it trump's the
trump's the president right now that's
why i support him she says
safe borders and he's our president and
i just love him because he loves america
so much he stands for everything america
is
and understand that this no no
particular offense to this woman this is
just trump
trump as a privileged new york city born
and raised guy
has spent his life trying to stay away
from uh women like this woman i'm not
picking on her in particular i mean it
applies to everybody
right the workers actually doing the
work building trump's real estate
projects
the people donating to trump's campaign
all of these people
are useful and valuable to trump only as
far as
they can they can assist him in whatever
his immediate goals are
he wants nothing to do with these people
in reality he's not racist like they say
he is
and um i love him that's why god too i
mean
and great people like you guys to bring
us together and tell us the real truth
i wish more people were watching and
hearing the real truth yeah
so there's just not you know the
language that's being used that is cult
language
that is cult language and you know i we
we've um
if you want more sort of texture
to understand that language and these
ideologies
check out the interview i did with
stephen hassan about
cultishness read the road to jonestown
about jim jones people's temple
i'm now reading going clear by lawrence
wright about scientology
it's trumpism it's trumpism that's what
it is when you when you read it and
and you then see these people that's
what it is let's go to another one of
these this one now is from newsmax uh
these are more interviews with trump
supporters at the rally
love trump i think he's the best thing
that happened to our country and now
it's being
destroyed what makes you love trump so
much free enterprise
system you know it's all about free
enterprise system and the second
amendment
and we're all pro cops of course and
understand
if you actually say to these folks
so what did trump do on second amendment
and then what did biden do
that is so restricting your ability to
own guns
i guarantee you they will not actually
be able to name anything trump
actually did on firearms he actually did
very little it was mostly rhetoric
and with biden they also will be unable
to name anything now biden has tried to
do a couple of things they're all
totally milk toast
establishing a commission to study x and
uh buckling down a little bit on ghost
gun sales which is not
you know it's a problem but it's not
going to restrict in all likelihood that
guy's ability to get guns
it's just made up it's there's nothing
there still a lot of great patriots in
this country and we're not going to let
the left take it from us
if this becomes socialism where in the
world
where will we go and again so this is
the effectiveness of propaganda
what's socialism what are you talking
about give us an exam i mean
listen when i when jesse lee peterson
interviewed me this promise sort of
prominent cartoonishly uh
prominent black conservative and he said
socialism socialism i said what's an
example of socialism under obama he said
what about those obama phones that's
what he was able to come up with there's
no substance here i want to keep
socialism
away from the united states oh i'm here
because
the country is not going in the right
direction how so
i will let you know that i was a
registered democrat since 1976.
can you tell me a little bit about your
message fight terrorism support israel
yeah it's really very simple
uh we have a threat from people
screaming death to america
death to israel same group same insanity
these people are so gross like their
their quote support of israel
is just it's it's disgustingly misplaced
and if we don't fight back we show our
weakness
i'm here to show that people still love
him even when he's
so far in retirement but we'll see what
happens the journey isn't over it's just
beginning
uh we have the opportunity to uh to make
america great again we hit a bump in the
road we got
knocked out australian guy apparently
loves trump over by the election by
covet but we're going to come back we'll
come back stronger than ever why is
trump having a rally
when there's three and a half more years
until he's he can run
and i said it's about hope it's awesome
and though the vibe here is so great and
everybody's so positive and everybody's
so excited there is a hope for america
there's a hope for our future
so that is uh that that is that and so
after the break i'm going to explain to
you why i believe
if trump runs in 24 joe and kamala are
in trouble we'll have more clips from
this event
um on our instagram which you can find
at davidpakmanshow follow me on
instagram at david.pacman see pictures
from
my recent escapades which i'll talk
about more
on today's bonus show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow okay so i i want to lay
this out now
just to get it on the record relatively
early normally i don't comment about an
election that's not
the immediate next election so in 2017
people would call in and they'd say
hey what do you think about 2020 this
that and i'd say we have to focus on
2018 that's the immediate question right
now
what happens in 2018 but i actually do
want to talk about 2024 today a little
bit because i worry that there's lots of
people just missing what's taking
place and not seeing what is
increasingly a very disturbing situation
the bottom line is this i believe that
if there's a so-called rematch in 24
between trump and biden that that's very
very bad for joe biden i don't think
that looks good
and if joe biden chooses not to run for
re-election
and it is kamala harris instead who is
the democratic presidential nominee
i think that that also doesn't look very
good and i'm going to lay out why
now i'm going to mention joe biden's age
here
joe biden would be 82 at the time of the
2024 election
donald trump would also be 78 at that
time and one might argue there's really
not that much difference it's just
two old white guys but the difference is
that donald trump has a cult
of followers a cult of personality
around him
that afflicts his supporters for whom
trump's age is not going to be a factor
while i believe that because of the
nature of joe biden's support
and because of the nature particularly
of the progressive wing of the
democratic party
and the preferences of democratic voters
the idea of voting
4 and 82 year old in 2024
is going to impact those more
predisposed to vote for joe biden
then it will affect those likely or
considering voting for donald trump
in 2024 so in other words what i'm
saying is biden's age
will work against him more than trump's
age will work against
trump so let's now get into my thought
process first and foremost
i'm getting the sense just at a base
level that
in general a so-called rematch is going
to be very tough for joe biden and in
addition to the concept of a rematch
or one of our reddit viewers put a post
up on our reddit that
calls it like a sort of final showdown i
think that it will invigorate the right
far more than it will invigorate the
left that's one scenario the final
showdown rematch
between trump and biden i don't think
it's very good for joe biden now there's
a different scenario that's possible
which is that joe biden as some suspect
might not run for a second term
in 2024 and then kamala harris will
either be handed
or might have to fight for the
democratic nomination
there's still a long time until 2024 but
all of those scenarios i think are also
problematic kamala harris has maintained
a relatively low
profile so far and she has low approval
ratings
that doesn't give me much confidence
about harris versus trump in 2024.
if you look at the latest real clear
politics average of approval polls
kamala harris is now underwater her
negatives
her disapproval is higher than her
approval for better or worse she's taken
some real hits when it comes
to her handling of the border now you
might say what handling
rightly or wrongly joe biden tasked her
with
the border problem her approval on that
is very low now it's early things could
change between now and 2024 but as of
right now
i am not at all confident that if kamala
harris is just handed the democratic
nomination meaning
biden says i'm not running but kamala
harris is running
and no serious democratic primary takes
place and she's the nominee
i don't think harris does well against
donald trump in 2024.
in fact i find it really difficult to
see a scenario where she wins
now the other scenario would be joe
biden says he's not running
and harris does run but there's a big
primary fight
which kamala harris ultimately wins
because of her low approval if kamala
harris has to fight her way through an
ugly primary to get that nomination
it also strikes me as a recipe for
disaster similar to 2016.
the third scenario would be biden
doesn't run
kamala fights for the nomination but she
loses
and someone else is the democratic
nominee
that i do think is too early to talk
about and
we just have no idea who that might be
we have no idea how they might
match up against donald trump it's just
too hypothetical but the two scenarios
i'm focused on
which are the the problematic ones which
are biden
does run for re-election or biden
doesn't and kamala's the nominee whether
she just gets it handed to her or she
fights for it and wins it
if you give me an even money bet today
i'm probably betting on trump in those
scenarios based on what i currently see
as the energy of the democratic party
and the energy of the republican party
part of it is that even in 2020
right there's this urgent emergency of
removing donald trump
uh the and the the energy and enthusiasm
around biden
was relatively muted now biden
fortunately won by many millions of
votes nationally
but it was small differences in just a
few states if they had gone the other
way trump would have won
it's similar to trump winning in 16 if
just a few states went
slightly differently hillary clinton
would have been the winner
in 2016. so that also makes me concerned
with trump four years in the rear view
mirror that there will be again
democrats who after eight years of obama
said i'm not
for whatever reason i'm not going to go
out and vote in this hillary versus
trump thing and then trump won
a repeat of that also scares me and then
in addition to that as we see
at these trump rallies the cult of
personality around donald trump
the fact that the republican party
whether they're pretending or whether
they seriously like trump it doesn't
matter they're they're
basically behind him they're not
abandoning him that
is uh troubling and there is really
i mean it really seems like there's
nothing trump can do to lose the support
that he has or at least most of it so
i think 2024 is real trouble in a
rematch against joe biden
or against kamala harris i'm not saying
i have a better idea
i think trump will be very strong in 24
if he's the
the nominee so if you have a different
perspective i would love to hear from
you and i understand i'm breaking my own
rule i usually only talk about the next
election but
the circumstances are unique and the
next election
is 22 but it relates so much to 24 that
we really have sort of like a three-year
period that i see as a package
in my mind so send me your thoughts
about this
and of course if 2022 goes disastrously
for the trumpian wing of the republican
party
that weakens trump dramatically
but i don't know that that's actually
going to be the outcome so let me know
how worried you are about this
if you agree disagree find me on twitter
at deepakman
one of the big things that happened
during our vacation is that the trump
organization
meaning trump's business uh and its cfo
alan weisselberg were indicted on
multiple criminal charges
15 felony counts against alan
weisselberg now this is significant
the charges are serious they involve a
tax fraud of various kinds
including failing to report and pay
taxes on a bunch of different benefits
cars
apartments school tuition it includes
state and federal income tax fraud
state and local tax fraud more generally
the reaction from the right and from
trump's family
exactly as everybody who's been paying
attention predicted has been
this is bogus politically motivated
nonsense
but of course because they can't seem to
resist trump's children don jr and eric
trump went on tv
and basically admitted they did all the
stuff they admit to it in the context of
saying this is small potatoes
they admit to it in the context of
saying we're only being targeted for
this for political reasons but
they admit to it much like trump did at
his rally in florida over the weekend
they both
don jr and eric had complete meltdowns
in this first clip
we're going to look at newsmax host eric
balling
asking eric whether he thinks hero's
siblings might be indicted
and eric just loses his mind and starts
talking about
hunter biden if you can believe it let's
take a look at this here eric
are you concerned that they may send
into indictment your way your brother's
way or your sister's way
you know what i'm not eric because guess
what you know we've always lived
amazingly clean lives and believe me if
they could have they already would have
right there is no way
that this was going on 15 years at the
trump organization
and none of the trumps knew nothing
happens at the trump organization
without trump
or one of his kids knowing it it's just
not plausible
i mean that's what they wanted that was
their end goal you know the difference
is i'm not hunter biden
i'm not selling paintings to undisclosed
people for half a million dollars a
piece i'm not doing
you know drugs there's no reason to
believe there's anything criminal
in what hunter biden is doing with his
paintings in in shady hotels i'm not
i'm not going out and soliciting
prostitution and i'm not going out and
you know selling influence to ukraine
and china and having lavish trips paid
for a while
you know my fault those things can all
be investigated but it's not
the subject of this interview father's
commander-in-chief no i'm not doing that
you know what we do
don ivanka and i live really you know
nice clean lives and we work very very
hard and guess what
long before politics ever came into you
know our lives
we were in the business world and we
were successful and we worked very hard
and we lived clean lives it was very
different than the bidens
who were never in business until their
father actually got into politics and
and they've milked it for everything
it's worth and they still do it to this
day and
you know eric where is the d.a there you
know when you have text messages of of a
prostitute so much of what he's talking
you know the
the d.a a lot of that stuff is in
different jurisdictions there are
allegations many of which have been
looked into and found to be completely
baseless
just melting down completely now in this
next clip from fox news
eric trump admits these are employment
perks
everything that's alleged is true but it
simply shouldn't be a criminal matter
he's saying
you know eric you don't have to do these
interviews i don't think he knows that
yeah well these are employment perks
these are
you know these are um you know a
corporate car which everybody has i
guarantee you there's people
who doesn't have a corporate car guys
come on this network that has corporate
cars i guarantee you there's people in
every
company in the country that have
corporate vehicles this is what they're
going after this isn't a criminal matter
this is
you know it's really interesting raymond
after the financial crisis
right they didn't so you see what he did
there he admitted admitted to all of it
but he says this just
isn't a criminal matter or what he means
is it shouldn't be that's his opinion
but he's admitting to the stuff that's
what's amazing after a single person on
wall street despite the fact that these
people were literally they took down the
u.s economy but they'll go down they'll
go after somebody after
fringe employment benefits is that
really what the dea is focused on as
little girls are getting shot in the
middle of times square they'll go after
a corporate vehicle and a corporate
apartment give me
understand that there's not a single
denial here he's admitting all of it
he's just saying they shouldn't be
focused on this
break and honestly i have to say the
media has actually been very fair about
this
the new york times um you know so many
of the different news outlets
they've literally said this isn't this
isn't criminal this isn't worth
well 40 50 investigators and it did it
this would normally
be this would normally be a civil
complaint uh
okay so there there is that and then don
jr
um on fox news with uh dan bongino
also admitting all of it but just saying
this shouldn't be the focus of the
criminal system
yeah they they dressed up the indictment
obviously they dress it up they make it
look really serious
they say he didn't pay taxes on 1.7
million dollars worth of stuff over 16
years
so that's to new york state 8 of that
136 000
half of that was because my father paid
for his grandchildren's
school in new york city did you so
that's one of the allegations
that donald trump just directly paid
alan weisselberg's grandkids tuition
uh that has to be taxed if i have a
business lease
the amount that my business pays for my
car lease
i'm i have to pay taxes on that that is
a benefit and
that's a lot less money than what we're
talking about here for tuition don
is basically saying it was over a long
period of
time and it's not that much money per
month but he's admitting it all
so you take that out it amounts to about
five grand a month oh that's what they
promised they
brought in outside prosecutors they
teamed up with the attorney general of
new york state to do this
so while so there it is not denying any
of it their
their strategy is admit it all in plain
sight
but say it shouldn't be criminal and
there's prosecutorial discretion that's
being applied
in a politically biased way do they know
they don't have to do these interviews
and that they don't have to say these
things or is this genuinely the only way
they can think of to defend themselves
to say yeah i mean we kind of did it all
but none of it should be illegal or at
least it should be a civil issue
or at least they should go after
somebody else disastrous and
they've essentially over the weekend don
jr eric and donald trump himself at his
rally in sarasota
they admitted to all of it but they're
saying it just really isn't that serious
unbelievable and we'll see if that
defense works out for them it actually
may
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this
subscribe to our youtube channel at
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show you can
watch the full hour-long show you can
watch the show
in shorter clips you'll see all of our
interviews and everything else from the
show
you can go back and watch all of that
content from past
shows dating all the way back to 2009
interact with other viewers politely in
the comments section
and when you subscribe to our youtube
channel make sure to click that
bell button to be notified about every
new video just go to youtube.com
slash the david pakman show i'll see you
there i'm there every day
so there's growing uh pressure so called
from republicans for joe biden to be
screened for dementia like donald trump
was and this all relates to the montreal
cognitive assessment or the moca as it's
called which donald trump you might
remember took during his time
in the white house and trump hasn't
stopped bragging about the results ever
since even
at one point remember telling reporters
like chris wallace accusing them during
an interview
you couldn't do as well as me on those
tests and
trump keeps calling it a cognitive test
trump brags about his great score and
how it proves
something i guess about his intelligence
the reality is i've told you before is
that this test is meant to screen out
serious dementia pretty serious advanced
dementia sometimes used to evaluate
patients after strokes to see
what their cognitive functioning is it's
not really something
to brag about it's just a very crude and
basic
screening tool to find out is something
really wrong here where someone has
forgotten you know what a camel
looks like now you might be wondering
why is this an issue now
again this is present now because
trump won't stop talking about it and dr
uh ronnie jackson
trump's former white house doctor who's
now a congressman
um is saying that joe biden should take
the test uh don jr is saying joe biden
should take the test
donald trump has now started saying that
joe biden should take the test but in so
doing
trump just can't control himself he
can't stop bragging about the test
trump went down to the u.s mexico border
with republican governor of texas greg
abbott
and they had like a little press event
and somehow
trump gets on the topic of his dementia
test and how biden should take the test
take a look at this
but he did a test did i ace it
i aced it and i'd like to see biden he
said he won't ace it he'll get the first
two there's 35
questions and the first two or three are
pretty easy
they're the animals is this a lion a
giraffe
when he gets to around 20 he's going to
have a little hard time i think he's
going to have a hard time with the first
few actually
but uh so we really have something now
trump is just wrong about
basically everything as usual there
aren't 35 questions there are 30 points
there's really like 19 or 23 questions
depending on
how you count them so like even trump's
recollection of what the test is is
wrong
but he keeps insisting with it but
somehow
trump is obsessed with the test here he
is talking to sean hannity also at the
border part of his
mexico border propaganda tour that he
did last week during our vacation
listened to trump and sean hannity
helping to push this nonsense about the
difficulty of the test
i'm in trouble with this we aced it i
think i can say that i aced it
did he get one he didn't get one
question wrong did he 30 out of 30.
wow i have to tell you the crowd
cheering is just something else i mean
they're they're cheering for what is a
normal
state they're cheering for not suffering
from serious dementia these are people
who would clap for
anything consider what it is they're
clapping for it's pathetic
the president passed the test meant to
screen
for serious cognitive impairment yeah
what a manly guy our leader here's the
rest of the clip and trump again saying
the test is just
much tougher than the media will tell
you and they did get a little more
difficult after you got by 15 i would
say but
i heard the first three questions are is
it a giraffe or an elephant right
well you know that's what the fact is
they take the first two or three
questions and they put that
and they put them in but let me tell you
they would not get those last
15 right certainly not the last 10 that
i can tell you but
anyway so again dr ronnie jackson
trump's former doctor now just a
bomb-throwing congressman
also pushing this and uh saying
um that something is going on biden
needs a test
and just to remind you about the test by
the way
this really is an easy test um we've got
it up on the screen i mean it's
you know stuff like draw a clock that
shows
that it's 11 10 identify
a lion a rhino and a camel
remember repeat back to me the words
face
velvet church daisy red read a list of
digits and then you know you count them
back like the
the tester would say two one eight
five four and you have to say two one
eight five four or repeat the numbers
backwards
seven four two and you say two four
seven
um subtract by seven out loud you know
like a hundred ninety three eighty six
seventy nine
this is the test um when trump says
there are tougher questions
you know there's one called abstraction
which is like what are the similarities
between
train and bicycle to which you would say
oh sir those are
methods of transportation or uh you know
things republicans oppose
depending on your perspective a watch
and a ruler well both of those
help you measure different things the
watch measures time and the ruler
measures length
this is what they're this is the
difficult test that trump is talking
about so
it's all pathetic um it seems to be
another distraction narrative
quite frankly and it is bizarre that
donald trump is still obsessed with it
real quick uh i want to mention that
there was a
bizarre and horrifying event in
philadelphia that kind of went
wacky um white supremacists participated
in a rally a march in philadelphia
meant to be about supposed election
integrity by which they mean that trump
really won
check out this report from huffpost a
white supremacist group based in texas
attempted a march on philadelphia over
the uh independence day weekend
but had to celebrate the holiday the
confederate way
they literally ran away from the people
of philadelphia michael crum a police
officer in the city
told the local abc station wpvi
about 200 masked and khaki clad members
of the patriot front organization
listed as a white nationalist hate group
by the southern poverty
law center marched on the city in the
saturday night
incident nbc philadelphia reported they
chanted about the election and reclaimed
america engaged in pushing and shoving
with people
and took a reporter's cell phone but
that boldness quickly faded
as more residents turned out they
started engaging with citizens of
philadelphia
who were none too happy about what they
were saying these males felt threatened
and at one point somebody in their crowd
threw a type of smoke bomb to cover
their retreat they're they're treating
this like a tactical event they covered
their retreat
philly mayor jim kenny said he was
appalled that the group chose his city
for its demonstration
saying while we respect everyone's right
to exercise free speech
our administration stands against
everything these groups represent
racism intolerance and hate have no
place here
there are videos of white supremacist
groups using
what looked to be toy shields to protect
themselves
it's all just absolutely and completely
bizarre
one member of the white supremacist
group was hit and fell when another
member
pulled the truck's roll-up door down
slamming him in the head
in the process i'm not going to play the
clip but it is there
there were no arrests nor were there
reports of injuries or damage so of
course
i'm not for violence of any kind i'm not
for violence by the protesters and
assuming that it is not in self-defense
i'm also not for violence against these
people couple interesting notes here
number one
it's great that this went a different
way than charlottesville virginia
early in donald trump's presidency of
course you never want to see that
number two it's not lost on me that
the people that are clinging on to the
trump really one narrative
include all sorts of uh of radicals
including in this case white
nationalists and it's good that
the government is paying attention to
the fact that that's a reality
and then number three again uh does it
matter
whether the white nationalists really
think trump won
or whether they are just using it as an
excuse to get out there and cause chaos
it doesn't really matter much the same
way that
there's people who say trump's
anti-semitic and then the counter is
trump's not anti-semitic
his son-in-law's jewish his daughter
converted to judaism his grandkids are
jewish
oh but you could still have jewish
family and be anti it doesn't matter
if he emboldens and coalesces the
anti-semitic people
and the white nationalists what is deep
in trump's mind doesn't actually really
matter the actions are what matter here
and the actions in this particular case
are that all sorts of radicals
are getting involved in this i i hate i
feel stupid even calling it election
integrity movement
it's really a wreak havoc and try to
steal the election movement
uh all of those groups are getting
involved and we'll see what impact they
have
on the 2022 election quite frankly we
have a voicemail number you can call
anytime we had
hundreds and hundreds of voicemails
waiting for us
when we got back from our vacation
let's listen to one who is pointing out
you know david
these live streams are getting so crazy
that it's almost impossible to even use
the chat function
i there's something funny and quaint
about this one take a listen
hey david i just wanted to say i
apologize if i'm
anyway i'll just say it um can you make
some sort of statement for your um
live shows about the live chat
because people just speed through and
there's a hundred statements and you
can't even read it it's like right
there's no interaction at all it's just
a lot of
like word salad well well
word salads should be the motto for
youtube live stream chat yeah
i mean i agree at 100 miles an hour
so there's no conversation like no i
wish youtube had like a uh
you know you could only make a statement
maybe every five seconds
it's called slow mode we use it uh we
have it turned on
it's actually set to 10 seconds but it's
just it they get crazy i admit it
because there's something like that
but it's just insane like if there's
you might as well not even have it
turned off
[Laughter]
there's something so quaint and
delightful about you know
during these when this when the stream
has a lot of people watching it
the live chat is almost completely
worthless and unusable and
and it's unclear whether it should even
be on i completely agree with you yeah
that's why i don't even look at it
uh and maybe you shouldn't either but i
i just love that it's like
welcome to the internet my friend yeah
that's how it works no but we do use
slow mode
we could slow it down even more we could
set it to 30 seconds but
sometimes people get frustrated we we
want we want the chat to be available to
people who want it
much like youtube comments but it's also
easy to ignore
it and them the live chat and comments
uh respectively
if you just want to focus on the content
so my view is something for everyone
have everything turned on but only use
what you like
today's bonus show i will tell you
wacky anti-vaxx stories
from my vacation in florida
some of the things happened in florida
some of the things happened in florida
and you'll know which or which as i
explain it to you on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com we'll hear about what
pat was up to
it'll be great and i'll speak to you
then